à travers ces quelques lignes que daniel
colling président du printemps de
bourges dé prendre ses responsabilités
en confirmant le maintien du concert
d'orelsan à l'origine de la polémique la
chanson vitriol de l'artiste dans
laquelle il menace de violence physique
son ex femme qui l'a trompé les paroles
qui ont attiré les foudres de la classe
politique et des associations
c'est le cas du conseil régional
partenaire de l'opération qui souhaitait
sa déprogrammation
il refuse de mettre de l'argent public
dans ce concert
la subvention attribuée au festival sera
ainsi légèrement amoindrie lorsque on
s'exprime publiquement en engagent un
certain nombre de valeurs on engage des
choix et aujourd'hui dans notre région
des gens des associations sont très
légitimement choqués par les choses qui
ont été produites et écrit ils me disent
est ce qu'il y à soutien de la région à
cet artiste la programmation de cet
artiste alors qu'il tient des propos qui
sont éminemment chez dans éminemment
irrespectueux éminemment blessant pour
les organisateurs cette décision
s'apparente à un acte de censure il
explique que cette chanson ne saura pas
d'interpréter sur scène et laisse
entrevoir en filigrane leur
incompréhension quant aux pressions dont
ils font l'objet le printemps de bourges
et très perplexe de voir qu'un président
d'une collectivité puisse conditionner
une subvention vers un artiste mais rien
n'y fait l'association ni ni
soumises a elle aussi décidé de donner
de la voix
forte et surtout au printemps de bourges
c'est un grand festival il y aura pas
mal de jeunes et pas mal de gens qui
sont voilà qu'ils font quand même un
militant le concert est qui et qui
participent à cet événement là pour moi
je pense que même les vents d'émulateurs
de l'événement non non non écouter
vraiment les
polémiques ou pas le printemps de
bourges invite le public à découvrir
orelsan le samedi 25 avril un artiste de
hip hop français qu'il juge excellents
et vaud présente hâtif de la génération
des 20 ans